so I think I want to get something like
Navy not anything too heavily pattern
because I think that's just gonna make
it look cheap today we'll be buying
suits off of Amazon not Supes suits I'm
gonna try a nun suit and maybe a fan
anyone oh I'm a little worried about a
pants because men's pants they don't cut
for bum and hips which I have created to
birth children so you actually know more
about suits than I do
cuz you made a video where you got it
sooo what's very good on you
thank you so you've definitely had more
suit experience than I have I want
patterns colors so I should try to get a
more normal suit let's go let's go order
our suits
okay fashion that's what we're here for
okay so we got a lot of suits DVDs
here's van Houston $100 this is pants
and jacket and you can get it in two
days Wow
we got a knife at bed this is like I'm
selling ice cream on the pier dark green
double-breasted this is a party tuxedo
for men that's exactly what I need I
think I found my suit your turn so I
would love some pattern Wow leave a
trail of sequins where no one will look
good in this item the thing a floral
print is is it cute or is it ugly it's
very hard to find it in between that one
really yeah all right but I could look
like a peacock conductor Annie is this
ugly or cute do you like this one I like
the first one that's very very good
I do like Vampire Weekend I kind of want
to get that peacock jacket I think I got
yeah okay I'm just gonna steal yours
this one doesn't actually look like a
peacock yes it absolutely does do you
like the red one and I'll get the black
one I walk I don't want us to both have
to read
should the exciting seats go well it'll
be the most shipping explosive display
of clothing ever
it's like Christmas Merry Christmas from
the Amazon fairy see a sequin don't
people like to knit for you this is my
sequined peacock
oh nice bag oh dear oh God
shinier than I thought it would be oh oh
the lining though nice extra small oh my
god what what hold Emma floor I can get
this over my clothes and it would still
be too big this is an extra small is the
rest of this video I was going to Clown
College there's some more stuff in the
bag here what oh good a cumberbund
there's also bowtie oh yeah
I do pertain to men's suits I do but
this is bonkers it's like in the little
rascals where they like sit on top of
each other and try to go to the bank
maybe the peacock distracts from the
ill-fitting nature really I'm very
disappointed
we measured too you know everything in
the 90s was three times too big oh oh
God I'm curious to see how it's gonna
fit you cuz you got one size up from
this yeah that's yours but how's your
pants
here's are my pants they might be okay
yeah these are actually too tight on me
come on cubes benedict member bonnie i
mean this isn't supposed to go over a
t-shirt so it actually fits me look at
this they're not supposed to flap oddly
it's definitely tight you're supposed
bigger than mine this is so weird to me
those jewels though a jeweled with the
t-shirt I look fully like maybe a
stripper a magician stripper
are there any magicians troopers let's
try the other one maybe I'll have better
luck you
need to be fine okay go yeah these are
definitely better this at least kind
know one thing I noticed is that these
buttons don't fit through the
buttonholes
what try to get that through there like
what are these for
I mean it's double breath he's pretty
much nailed my nipples by the way you
look very business managed this color is
nice on you the colors on the website
made this look much more bold than it
actually is like these are pretty muted
colors like I can't walk normally like I
want to check a pocket watch oh you got
your button to work yeah that is jammed
through see that you look relatively
true you look charming also why is it
just on the outside of your pants
oh the medium is on the outside of my
pants that's just to let people know I
mean we did pay like 80 bucks for a suit
which is like good suits can range up to
like $1000 for 80 bucks I have a suit
that fits
I think suits are often taken a little
too seriously okay this is like a very
fun approach to suit wearing if you need
to look like a cop for Halloween you've
nailed it a detective yeah what do you
think
[Music]
okay better yet